meet Brianna cuoco Kaley cuoco's younger
sister the triple-threat has
guest-starred on the Big Bang Theory and
appeared as a contestant on The Voice in
2013
but her next gig is a little different
she's playing real-life axe-murderer
lizzie borden elizy the musical I just
have met so many people over the years
that look at me and they're like experts
I see it you know what I mean if they
always knew how sweet you are believe
it's rock like heavy rock music which I
love singing personally and she's so
fascinating I mean she's obviously has a
little bit of screws loose up in there
which is so fun to play I'm so excited
the 27 year old singer and her sister
are extremely close and their loyalty
runs pretty deep I love that she's so
protective of you are you equally as
protective of her yes people can be
especially mean on you know Instagram
social media stuff and I have found that
I've I'm like your loss yeah oh so you
interact with the other haters what do
you do I shut them down my sister fangs
come out seriously and does she ever see
these things and go Bree what are you
doing you're interacting with these
people
she's actually I'm thinking two specific
times and she actually texted me she
says thanks for having my back
despite Briana saying they're naturally
opposites and don't compete for the same
roles she does take Kaylee's advice
about the industry to heart don't be a
jerk keep your feet on the ground you
know do work hard don't take yourself
too seriously don't be a jerk just be a
good human and work hard and things